hello I'm Greg Sadler and I would like
to ask you a favor something I don't
usually do in my YouTube videos but this
time I actually do have to bring it up
so for years people have been telling me
that they've been seeing my videos in
academic classes because their
instructors have been using them
primarily for philosophy classes perhaps
for some others as well or I've also
heard from a few people who are college
professors that they themselves use my
videos now I don't have any problem with
that I'm happy to see the videos getting
play and helping people out and I'll
talk a little bit more about that in a
minute but here is the favor so if you
have seen my videos in an academic class
or if you're using my videos in an
academic class let me know put it in a
comment or you know on this video for
example or perhaps on the videos that
you're using it for because I want to
get some general idea obviously I'm not
going to get purely accurate numbers of
any sort but I want to get at least some
idea of the impact the range the scope
that all these videos that I've been
producing over the last you know 12 odd
years are having for people out there in
the academic world I'm happy that lots
and lots of lifelong Learners use the
videos find them useful but I want to
know who in traditional Academia
colleges universities I suppose they
could be used perhaps for high school as
well or other kinds of academic settings
I want to get some idea about what the
range of the videos are how many people
are in fact using them and what they're
using them for and I kind of also like
to know which videos are getting that
treatment that use so if you are using
them if you've seen them if your
instructors use them leave a comment
below and let me know what the
circumstances are failing that maybe
shoot me an email you know it's easy
enough to find my email you just go to
my YouTube channel and where it says for
business inquiries click here click
there now the reason I'm doing this is
as I mentioned lots and lots of people
have been telling me in a very sort of
haphazard way oh you know I I saw your
videos we used them in this class or
your videos were helpful for me and and
many of the comments that I get are
actually from lifelong Learners or other
students whose instructors aren't using
the videos but who found them very
helpful as a matter of fact a little bit
of a digression here one of the common
and unfortunate types of comments that
I've been getting since I started out in
YouTube is oh thank you for posting this
my instructor won't actually discuss
this material they just expect us to
learn it and so your video on Kant
Descartes Mary Wollstonecraft Aristotle
whoever it happens to be just saved my
grade or help me understand something
but we're more interested here in
instructors College instructors
University instructors who actually
recognize that there's at least some
value in these videos and are using them
as resources and you know my videos
because they're on YouTube and you can
watch them for free are what we call you
know Open Access oer resources and I put
them out there so that they can indeed
do that job of helping people to
understand
philosophy sometimes other topics and
disciplines as well but mostly
philosophy so I'm going to cut this
short here so once again the favor I'm
asking you if you have seen my videos in
an academic class not my own academic
classes but in somebody else's academic
class or if you are a college or
university or even high school
instructor and you have used my videos
in your classes
put a comment let me know which videos
you used what
thinkers text topics you were
particularly interested in and found
helpful for yourself and for your
students and maybe you could tell me
also like when you did it it was it 10
years ago was it two years ago are you
using them right now and I will you know
put these comments together or emails or
whatever else you send me and use it to
give me some better idea about the
impact that the videos that I've been
producing and providing for the last 12
or so years have had out there in this
vast fear that we call the internet so
that's it from me if you do that I'd be
really happy if you're not seeing my
videos in your classes and you want to
pester your instructor about that
maybe don't because they're probably not
gonna like that but you could do that
anyway and so I'll just I'll just cut
this short here and say thank you in
advance to anybody who is going to leave
the comments and you know if there's
enough interest if there's enough
responses I'll maybe do a follow-up
about the interesting responses that I
get to this but otherwise just thanks
for listening and if you've got some
useful information for me thanks for
providing it to me